像我這麼用下來皮膚都變得很很滑
臉上的豆豆壁口黑頭都少了很多
他呢 我想在零一天跟你們分享一下我的早晚用三油餐
我用了六年的酸薄的臉從那種反腹漲豆漲
壁口絲絲調成現在這種鼓液漲豆腐質
有道歉前的你們就按照我的方法來用三
不僅不會讓你爆豆米米
還會讓你臉上的豆豆壁口黑頭粉
4月的用月少
不言就是好看的這種水光機
我現在就喜歡你現在說成肩護膚
在白天我一般不會用這種特別猛的酸
因為在白天我們的人還要抵禁自外線的傷害
抵禁外界刺激和污染
所以白天我們越壓力很大的
那我白天就會用這種含酸的脚致潮淋酸
一方面不會給皮膚太大的負擔
另一方面又可以跟白天幫我們打開皮膚充道
減少一些早之堆肌
很多姐妹覺得妝容不服貼花妝的時候容易說
你其實很多時候就是因為我們的脚致堆肌導致道
那加了這一步之後
你們的妝容以及脫你的情況
我都會改善很多
這影片上次跟你們分享過
我很想用它
它裡面就是加了水養酸和一堆修復層次
可以很溫和的幫我們接觸的
超光怪線老費腳翅
豬肉毛口超級好用
我一般是會打它到我在這個年天小年的信心的
按壓在我們的抵禧
成人中這一塊就是
非常暗成的姐妹你們多暗
然後大家記者就是變好
如果你這邊好像容易敏敏
你要避開這層不去
很多女生這一塊都是比較薄的
避開這一塊的話
你們發現很用酸
就不能以後很命了
用它按壓完之後
我們的眼上還是很乾爽的
沒有那種年紀感
接著按按按按按按按按按按
有皮白切的一定要做好看的話
臉才不容易垮了按著
最後一步我會為這種這個
色修膠膠來替我的臉保暫護好
減少酸的刺激
這個我之前應該跟你們分享過
無數次了吧
只能不動數的次來使
而且我也把它用過嘛好幾個
它這個裡面呢
有感染液體曲誤
恐慕要存等等很厲害的一些修護成分
可以直接把紅明火開關在下面
修護效果是肉塊又直接
不僅如此
它也可以幫我們平衡省搖擺散
動硬體量膚色
敲乾這個嘴清爽一下我剛才
接著我幾個蠻多的
在臉上硬魔化水馬上就被提出生命局
臉上是這種任何而不逆的狀態
但它吸收完之後
就可以除防曬
然後跟妝了
出來的妝效特別好
看到的碗上心省就還是用
這個這樣子調劑水
搭配修護精華後續再來一個色修雙風層
那用三老手或者是用三到了平靜溪
值得鬥鬥鬥鬥
還是擋住不停的簡單
我們看推薦的神氏就是這奪
多三星的髮鬥
還用畢業了
它裡面有減少闢口
抗光量膚的果酸
有輸通毛口吸引皮膚的水氧酸
還有減少鬥鬥改善黑紅鬥硬的人大散
每一個單元出來都是很和我們有機會口的
自無合到一起就是強的那麽一邊
我的肉法是晚上洗完臉之後
把臉上水分全部擦乾
然後把它塗在踢起成周一些角度
這層比較厚的血雨
官方說每次服務分中
我自己用下來覺得服衣分中就夠了
因為它真的還挺長的
手機到幾十一分鐘
實在你到馬上就去空洗掉
除非你是那種很厚很厚的成強體
那你服他的時間可以再嘗一下
大家不用覺得負的時間短
就沒有效果
它是用的微波脫技術
可以精準的戴系的老費角質
不傷害平常同時還加了
十一種節奏成分來穩住皮膚
所以用完之後不容易乾燥脫皮
像我這麼用下來皮膚都變得很嫩很滑
臉上的鬥鬥必口黑頭都少了很多
長期用的話還能細膩毛孔提升複製
再加就能實現更加外面
機構用上一樣的效果
那把他洗到之後就記得
再塗一個修護徵華加色修面上
就可以去睡覺了
一般按照我這麼搭開優展的話
基本上就會出錯
但你如果實在是很怕翻車的話
也可以再加你們準備一部加一個包麥
這個包麥雙的修護力更強
修護品狀的效果也更牛
我之前翻車的時候
都是唱他幫我快速的機
就修護回來的
最後給你們膚上我的實用中間
大家可以保存起來
對照著來用